a veterinarian is studying a certain
disease that seems to be affecting male
cats more than female cats they obtain a
random sample of records from 500 cats
they find 24 of the 259
male cats have the disease while 14 of
241 female cats have the disease
the venerate the veterinarian uses these
results to test their null hypothesis
that the true proportion is the same
amongst the male and female cats versus
the alternative hypothesis that the
proportion of males who get the disease
is actually higher than the proportion
of females the test statistic was z is
equal to 1.46
and the p-value was approximately 0.07
that's useful they've done a lot of work
for us
assume that all conditions for inference
were met
at the alpha equals 0.10 level of
significance is there sufficient
evidence to conclude that a larger
proportion of male cats have the disease
so pause this video and see if you can
answer that
all right so remember what we do with
the significance test we assume
we assume
our null hypothesis
and then
given and then with that assumption we
look at our data and we calculate a p
value we say hey what is the probability
of getting the data that we did assuming
our null hypothesis is true
and if that is lower than our
significance level then we reject the
null hypothesis because we say hey
assuming the null hypothesis we got a
pretty unlikely event we reject it which
would suggest the alternative
and so here our p-value is
0.07 which is indeed less than our alpha
which is less than our significance
level this thing right over here 0.10
and so because of that we would reject
the null hypothesis
reject null hypothesis which would which
is we could say there is sufficient
evidence to conclude that a larger
proportion of male cats have the disease
so we could say suggests
suggests
the
alternative hypothesis
and so on khan academy there's some
multiple choice questions like this and
so the choice that you would pick might
be something like because our p-value is
less than our significance level we
would reject the null hypothesis and
that would suggest the alternative